Democrats are praising President Biden's
response to the Silicon Valley Bank
collapse but the New York Post pointing
out that the move is nothing more than a
bailout to his Rich donor base 98 of all
political contributions from Tech
employees went to Democrats in 2020 with
one Insider telling the post Silicon
Valley Bank is the Bank of the Democrats
they're looking after their own if it
was the bank of Mega what are the
chances it would be bailed out there's
not a chance in hell Democrats say Biden
did a bang-up job and is setting the
stage for more handouts to Americans
how we were able to protect jobs and how
we were able to get those payrolls done
so that these uh owners of these small
tech companies could pay their staffs
Etc we did them a miraculous job I
believe the FED did the right thing to
protect depositors and a lot of these
companies but when you look at Jackson
Mississippi when you look at East
Palestine Ohio when you look at folks
with student debt and medical debt they
see that the Congress isn't capable of
acting in three days the way they were
capable to act here and that is a big
issue in this country why is it that
some people who deserve relief get the
relief and others don't and part of the
question Greg is oh Republicans are
blasting President Biden and accusing
him of special treatment
this is a bailout they're going to pass
that fee on to Community Banks all every
Bank in America part of their Investment
Portfolio they made loans to very risky
Ventures based more on their liberal
wokeness than on the the actual uh
ability for that uh borrower to pay the
loans back now the question is do we
really have a limit on FDIC insurance if
you don't it becomes a moral hazard and
a perverse incentive for executives to
take more risks because there's a lot of
reward and no downside oh exactly what I
was going to say Greg your thoughts well
I am not a banking expert uh and uh I
everything that they just said is could
be right that these are woke investors
people on the board don't have the
expertise they searched out you know the
right virtue signal and they're what
write a box to take for identity instead
of economic competence which lets
everybody down but I don't think it's a
bailout to give relief to depositors I
just I I think that and I don't like the
setup of this team sport politics well
if it's a trump Bank it would be this
way well if it was this way that's
completely fabricated and you don't know
you should be you should try to Stave
off the idea of people running to the
banks right this is a small bank they
had some wacky uh a wacky board but you
have to deposit the reason why the FED
is there is to protect people's they
didn't do anything wrong if you put
money in a bank you know you didn't do
anything you didn't commit any sins
you're doing the right thing where are
you supposed to put your money Jesse a
bigger Bank a bigger bank that's exactly
like that's kind of the point one that's
supposed to be insured yes exactly
that's why I'm not an expert but I'm
also a hypocrite because I'm against
bailouts but I don't feel right like
this is a bailout I think the investors
should be on the hook I think that the
people that run the bank should be on
the hook but the people that just
deposited their money in there they did
you know are they required to do their
due diligence every time I don't I don't
do that no I do not I do not but part of
part of the issue here is that you know
the risk assessment is different in a
smaller Bank than a bigger bank and the
whole point the larger picture that I
see here is that the answer is never
larger government the answer is not
government when they talk about Congress
acting government meddling we know from
2008 that that's exactly the right way
to set up for more failure and every
dollar that the government spends is our
money to begin with
well I want to talk about how woke they
are because Harold with all due respect
yesterday was telling me this was not a
woke bank so I did some digging that is
first of all they pledged 75 million
dollars to Black lives matter and no one
on the bank's board is a banker there's
one Banker on the board and the rest of
them are Clinton and Obama Mega donors
then
Janet Yellen appoints this woman
probably a nice woman to oversee this
Bank she's the San Francisco Fed chair
and she's so excited on her first day of
the job at Malaysia makes a little video
and she kisses her wife goodbye at the
door and then she puts a little backpack
on and she goes to the bank and
everybody claps for her and they make a
little video and she knows nothing she's
supposed to oversee what's going on here
and she totally missed it not only did
she miss this bank's collapse she missed
inflation too but like Greg said she's
got her eyes all over diversity this
bank was all about gender equality you
know you say you want to be able to walk
and chew gum at the same time right if
you want to have pride month at the bank
if you want to do silly little skits
about inclusivity fine but keep your eye
on the balance sheet if you're if you're
doing all this woke stuff and you're not
looking at the finances then that's a
problem and that's what everyone has a
problem with is the priorities of the
bad every single business has this
problem there's for some reason the
priorities are changing and you're gonna
have like no one's looking for expertise
or competence and you can pick any
entertainment you could pick any
restaurants anything you want is going
to have this problem including federal
agencies Dana not only defense and
intelligence which are atrocious and a
different subject but also the SEC so
what I find so ironic is in the cleanup
so the doj is now investigating the SEC
is investigating an additional to civil
suits but what has the SEC been doing
this entire time they've been demanding
that these Banks and businesses comply
with carbon Footprints ESG diversity and
inclusion inclusivity they're not doing
anything to protect the actual investor
so why are they the ones that are now
going to be investigating them it is
very interesting and the justice
department looking into what was
happening two weeks before this Bank
fell I think is what I really want to
know about because if the head guy is
selling stocks and handing out bonuses
that should be a red flag and you know
nobody caught that and all of a sudden
Peter Thiel I mean he he caught winds
somehow so whoever's supposed to be
minding the hen house should have caught
it as well but they didn't and so what's
interesting too is how quickly this
happened so they were solving on
Wednesday and they're not on Friday that
was very quick and Kevin O'Leary from
Shark Tank was on our Newsroom this
morning and he thinks that the
government did overreact and that we're
heading down into this position where
you would have no private sector Banks
and you wonder why Elizabeth Warren is
licking her chops because she wants
nationalized government Banks she wants
all of those Banks to be backed up by
the federal government is that the right
thing to do I don't think so and I don't
think we can do that overnight I think
Congress actually has to have some sort
of a say in that we don't have it yet
and I do want to do a little what about
ISM because why not it's been you know
it's been 10 minutes I haven't done it
um
smaller Regional agriculture banks are
very important to Rural America so if
you are a farmer or a Rancher you
usually know your Banker I remember the
banker that my grandfather had he came
and he was a part of the cattle drive
and it was neighborly and you understood
and so if my grandfather needed to go to
the bank and say we're going to buy x
amount of cattle or we have this much
hay to sell can you help me out we need
to buy some more equipment we need to
finance it that guy understands that the
big bank at JP Morgan in New York
doesn't and that's why these Regional
banks are important
in lots of different sectors the
Mississippi Bank during covet was one of
the best at getting out PPP loans to
small businesses who legitimately
were applying for that money and needed
it in order to keep their business as
afloat so I think the would be
interesting if there was a thought
experiment I don't want this to happen
but would these Democrats who are
running to defend svb bank because
that's where all those donors are would
they defend an agricultural Bank
question to you Jesse
I'm going to go with yes there are a lot
of Democrats that are in elected office
in the Heartland they care about they
talk about a job tester as a great
example Heidi heitkamp who ended up
losing her election I mean
I I don't think that it's one of those
cases I think that Greg is right why is
it the depositor's fault and why for
some of these companies you're running a
business it is not your responsibility
to check on whether your bank is messing
up at this level every couple of months
and this is a story that started being
reported months ago the Wall Street
journals are talking about when you have
interest rate hikes at this level and
people are buying up treasury bonds
which are not supposed to be sold again
in five to ten years you're supposed to
get and then suddenly they're going to
turn around and start selling them the
market is not going to reflect what the
actual value of that of it is and
something that matters a lot to this and
Dana said it happened so quickly
banking a bank run is the tailor as old
as time right but being able to do a
bank run off your phone is what isn't
right that a few people can get on
Twitter start tweeting out get out get
out get out and suddenly 42 billion
dollars needs to leave your coffers
within 24 hours I mean that's an
impossibility and something that we have
to deal with I want to say something
about what the post said you know if it
was a a Maga Bank it basically was Peter
Thiel was one of the top five biggest
VCS they're a huge backer Donald Trump
2016 2020 in 2022 he resigned from the
board of meta he was one of the original
board members so that he could back JD
Vance he could join a trump aligned pack
for JD Vance and Blake Masters
um the this embarrassing thing seven
whatever Jesse was talking about all the
wokeness if you look at who's running
that bank it's a bunch of white guys and
three women and the jobs that those
three women have by the way are roles
that traditionally women have HR the CMO
and then the chief risk officer who
obviously was not doing a great job
there so you're saying that we needed
more white guys no I'm really not saying
that at all and in terms of ESG
investing so I was looking around for
Republicans who believe in it someone
like Steve Schwartzman who runs
Blackstone it's a huge pillar of their
business I have never encountered
someone who works in finance who cares
more about having black faces or trans
people at the table more than they care
about money so obviously investing in
these things is good for the bottom line
and it's not just some woke Venture
who's on the board is not who's running
these things well whoever running it is
an idiot yeah he just got wiped out
Becker is an idiot but that's not a
wokeness initiative sure that's a white
guy yes she junk in there too that makes
people solar panels and they have all of
newsom's Vineyards locked up in the bank
too Jesse Waters versus Steve
Schwartzman I I will pay to see it I'm
gonna go with Schwartzman too on this
but I think that you could you both can
be right no we can't yeah
what I was going to say is you're adding
another variable of pressure into a mix
that doesn't talk about profit you could
say oh this leads to making more money
there is no there's no way you can prove
that there's no oh this one will cause
you to make more money so it adds its
extra pressure to somebody that who
should only be focused on the numbers
and not on who what people look like
that's disease less profitable actually
if you look at the statistics I don't
want to go down that road with you
really continued everyone Hi everyone
I'm Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now